This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有2%. 我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at It Podcasts. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字 2%。可在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 The Look Back at It 播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英国。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个栏目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 learn the hard way。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。艾伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我动了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我整个人都惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十岁时生活的一些重大变化和转变及其对我们的意义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Worrying about what other people think about us can take up a lot of mental real estate. We kind of know that we shouldn't care. We know that we are loved, we know that no one is really watching us that closely. But for some of us, it's not really a choice. We are overwhelmed by this deep, persistent fear of being perceived. We're constantly aware of those invisible judgments that others might be making, what parts of us they might not like, who we might offend, if we say the wrong thing, who we make cringe. And it keeps us in this place
对我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们二十岁的心理。担心别人怎么看我们可能会占据我们大量的精神资源。我们其实知道自己不该在意。我们知道自己是被爱的，我们知道其实没有人那么密切地关注我们。但对我们中的一些人来说，这其实并不是一种选择。我们被这种深刻而持久的被审视的恐惧所淹没。我们时刻意识到别人可能在做出那些无形的判断，我们身上的哪些部分可能是他们不喜欢的，如果我们说错了话，我们可能会冒犯谁，我们会让谁感到尴尬。这让我们停留在这样一个地方
of self-denial, denial of our true selves, of our potential, of our ambitions, of our authenticity. And today, I want to talk about it because it's a fear that is definitely not spoken about enough, despite being something that a lot of us in our 20s and beyond manage on a daily basis. Being in this decade of life, it comes with a lot of insecurity for sure, you know. It's our first decade of adulthood. And when you're, you're not. normally lost, we're lonely, maybe we're trying to fit in, and this fear of being perceived feeds on these worries to make us feel even more out of place and insecure. What you may not know is that there is a lot more to be said about this than just the typical explanation that we get
自我否定，否定真实的自我、潜力、雄心和真实性。今天，我想谈谈这个话题，因为这绝对是一个讨论度不够的恐惧，尽管我们二十多岁及以上的人每天都在应对这种恐惧。处于生命的这个十年，确实伴随着很多不安全感，你知道的。这是我们作为成年人的头十年。而当你处于这种状态时，你。通常会感到迷茫，感到孤独，也许我们正试图融入集体，而这种被注视的恐惧助长了这些担忧，让我们感到更加格格不入和缺乏安全感。你可能不知道的是，关于这一点，除了我们通常得到的解释之外，还有很多话要说。
of social anxiety or low self-confidence. Our fear of being perceived has its roots in early experiences of social exclusion, bullying, even perfectionism and how our brains process social and emotional information. Learning about this really helps us accept this reality that has kind of been thrust on us, right? And with that knowledge comes power, the power to kind of change the thought loop that keeps us fearful and withdrawn. And when you break down the irrational and fear-dependent thoughts that keep us trapped by other people's potential judgments, a huge weight is really lifted. And that's really what I want for you. We're also going to discuss three powerful mental shifts that I've used that are backed by research and psychology that can help you overcome your
关于社交焦虑或低自尊。我们对被审视的恐惧，根源于早期被社交排斥、霸凌、甚至完美主义的经历，以及我们的大脑处理社交和情感信息的方式。了解这一点确实有助于我们接受这种强加给我们的现实，对吧？伴随着这种认知而来的还有力量，一种改变思维循环的力量，正是这种循环让我们感到恐惧和退缩。当你剖析那些让我们被他人潜在评判所困住的非理性和恐惧驱动的想法时，一块巨石真的落地了。这正是我想为你做的事。我们还将讨论我用过、且有研究和心理学支持的三种强大的心理转变，它们可以帮助你克服
fear of being perceived, from playing mind games with your mind games to decentering the opinions of others through exposure and also applying one of the greatest. cognitive tricks of all time to essentially stop your anxiety about other people's opinions before they even begin. There is so much to talk about. And I also want to explore what can happen when we do this. What is the reality of being free from our fear of being perceived? So much becomes possible. I just think it's something that a lot of us can't even imagine, but I kind of want to show you what that might look like. So there is a lot of to unpack in this episode and I know from hearing from all of you that this is not uncommon in the
害怕被审视的恐惧，从对你的心理游戏玩心理游戏，到通过曝光将他人的看法去中心化，并应用有史以来最伟大的技巧之一。认知诀窍，在别人对你的看法的焦虑甚至开始之前就从根本上阻止它。有太多东西要聊了。我还想探讨当我们这样做时会发生什么。摆脱害怕被审视的恐惧，真实的感受究竟是怎样的？无限的可能将向我们敞开。我只是觉得这是我们很多人甚至无法想象的，但我想向大家展示那会是什么样子。所以这一期内容非常丰富，而且我从你们所有人的反馈中了解到，这绝不是
slightest. So for all of you who are managing this, dealing with this episode is for you to get that clarity, to feel seen, to know the psychology and of course to overcome it. So without further ado, let's get into how you can overcome your fear of being perceived. Our fear of being perceived really comes down to this irrational anxiety around being observed and scrutinized by others. It's kind of in the name really. But this fear is also known as scopophobia. And that comes from the Greek word scope to be examined. And of course, phobia to fear.
微不足道的少数现象。所以，对于所有正在应对、处理这种情况的听友们，这一期就是为了让你获得清晰的认知，让你觉得被看见，了解背后的心理学，当然，最终战胜它。废话不多说，让我们来看看如何克服你对被审视的恐惧。我们对被审视的恐惧，归根结底是对被他人观察和审视的这种非理性的焦虑。其实名字里就说得很清楚了。但这种恐惧也被称为广场恐惧症或视线恐惧症。这个词源于希腊语 scope，意为被检查。当然，phobia 代表恐惧。
Anytime something contains the word phobia in it, we know that what's really happening below the surface is anxiety. There is a dysregulated response to a persistent, irrational thought. or worry. You might say, you know, okay, scropophobia, yeah, it has its own name, but isn't this just social anxiety? And you would be totally right for thinking that the fear of being perceived and social anxiety often go hand in hand.
任何包含 phobia 这个词的东西，我们都知道表面之下真正发生的是焦虑。这是对持久的、非理性的想法或担忧的失调反应。你可能会说，你知道，好吧，广场恐惧症，是的，它有自己的名字，但这不就是社交焦虑吗？如果你这样认为，那就完全正确了。害怕被审视和社交焦虑往往是齐头并进的。
But this is more than simply a social phobia around wanting to avoid being seen by others. It's also a specific phobia. And specific phobias surround an extreme fear of a specific situation. that poses little to no danger, but makes people really, really anxious. The thing is, your fear of being perceived can be isolated to just a single environment. Like, you may have no trouble public speaking, hosting parties, even being seen by strangers on the street, but when it comes to dating, you are incredibly fearful of what people might think of you on your first date or on dating apps.
但这不仅仅是对想要避免被他人看到的社交恐惧。它也是一种特定恐惧症。特定恐惧症围绕着对特定情况的极度恐惧。这种情境几乎不构成危险，但却让人感到非常非常焦虑。问题是，你对被审视的恐惧可以孤立于单一环境。比如，你可能在公开演讲、举办派对、甚至在大街上被陌生人看到时完全没有问题，但一谈到约会，你在第一次约会或交友软件上就对别人怎么看你感到非常恐惧。
So you avoid those situations altogether. that's a specific trigger for your phobia of being perceived. Or you may be really confident in every other setting other than in the workplace or at the gym. That's why this fear can be very specific in nature. It's at this point that it's probably important to note that there are kind of two versions or two varieties to our fear of being perceived. There is the fear of being physically perceived, taking up space, being seen by others, which is probably the most common,
所以你干脆完全避开这些情况。这就是你对被审视恐惧的特定触发点。或者，除了在职场或健身房，你在其他任何场合都非常自信。这就是为什么这种恐惧本质上可以非常具体。正是在这一点上，可能值得注意的是，我们对被审视的恐惧有两种版本或两种变体。一种是害怕被物理上地感知，占据空间，被别人看到，这可能是最常见的，
and then there is the fear of being emotionally perceived, which has more to do with being seen deeply and intimately by someone else on a more kind of feelings-based level. It's less common, but it's still a really difficult reality to believe that if anyone were to truly see you and your character and to know you, they probably wouldn't want to be around you anymore. Physical, like our fear of physical perception is more around people making assumptions.
然后是害怕被情感上感知，这更多地与被别人深深地、亲密地从某种更基于情感的层面看到有关。这不太常见，但仍然是一个非常难以接受的现实：如果有人真正看到你和你的性格并了解你，他们可能就不会想再和你在一起了。物理上的，比如我们对物理感知的恐惧更多围绕着人们的假设。
oftentimes though they kind of go hand in hand because perception alone isn't scary right it's the judgment that comes next and that is where kind of the emotional element comes in it's not that we kind of think that someone looking at us is inherently dangerous that their eyes are going to like burn holes in our skin even if it might feel that way sometimes it's what we know comes second people make instantaneous and snap calls around what they think someone is like within seconds or minutes. And perception is not objective. There is not one clear way of seeing everything and everyone. It's objective.
不过通常它们是相辅相成的，因为仅仅被感知并不可怕，对吧？接下来随之而来的是评判，这正是情感元素发挥作用的地方。并不是说我们觉得有人看着我们本身就是危险的，他们的眼睛会像烧穿我们的皮肤一样，尽管有时感觉确实如此，而是我们知道接下来会发生什么。人们在几秒钟或几分钟内，就会对某人是什么样的人做出即时的、瞬间的判断。感知并不是客观的。看待万事万物并没有一种清晰明确的方式。它是客观的。
So we can't control what they think about us, whether that is correct or not. And that is often what is really at the root of this experience. We don't actually fear the act of being perceived physically. we fear being judged and we fear the unknowns that are contained in those judgments. And here is where we kind of return to that distinction between fear and anxiety. Fear is for the present and anxiety is for the possibility. That's where all the fun is in for our anxiety, right? Our anxiety likes to try to figure things out that we may never know and that unknown is so scary.
所以我们无法控制他们对我们的看法，无论这种看法是否正确。这往往才是这种体验的真正根源。我们其实并不害怕被物理感知的行为。我们害怕被评判，我们害怕这些评判中所包含的未知。在这里，我们回到了恐惧和焦虑之间的区别。恐惧是针对现在的，而焦虑是针对可能性的。这就是我们的焦虑所充满乐趣的地方，对吧？我们的焦虑喜欢试图弄清楚那些我们可能永远不会知道的事情，而未知是如此可怕。
We catastrophize based on the worst case scenario. rather than what is most likely, which is that people pay a lot more attention to themselves than anyone else. Most people are actually fairly kind with their judgments, and even if they aren't, we're still going to be okay. We can survive someone not liking us based on limited information. We can survive someone not liking us based on their own insecurities because it's not about us anymore. But let's kind of track back for a second because there is something crucial I've missed here that is what is it exactly about those invisible judgments that are so scary for people with a fear of being perceived? Yes, it is the fact that it is an unknown which our anxiety thrives on, but it also is a little bit more than that.
我们根据最坏的情况而不是最有可能的情况来灾难化，而最有可能的是，人们把更多的注意力放在自己身上，而不是任何人身上。大多数人在做出判断时其实都相当善良，即使他们不这样，我们依然会没事的。我们可以从有限的信息中挺过来，即便有人不喜欢我们。我们可以挺过有人因为他们自己的不安全感而不喜欢我们，因为这不再关乎我们了。但我们先倒回一步，因为我这里漏掉了一个至关重要的事情，那就是：对于那些害怕被审视的人来说，这些无形的判断究竟有什么可怕的？是的，事实是它是一个未知数，而我们的焦虑正是靠未知数滋养的，但它也稍微不止于此。
Social judgment holds a lot of power because of our innate ingrained fear of social disapproves. We don't want others not to like us. We don't want them to think that there's something wrong with us. We don't want them to walk away from meeting us or hanging out and go and say terrible things that might ruin our reputation or destroy certain relationships. This is really the case for a few reasons. Firstly, we kind of fear others' opinions out of a need to protect our self-esteem and to continue to validate ourselves.
社会评判拥有巨大的力量，因为我们对社会不赞同有着一种天生的、根深蒂固的恐惧。我们不希望别人不喜欢我们。我们不希望他们认为我们有什么问题。我们不希望他们在见面或闲逛后离开，然后说出可能毁掉我们的名誉或破坏某些关系的糟糕的话。这种情况的发生确实有几个原因。首先，我们害怕别人的意见，是出于保护自尊和继续自我验证的需要。
We don't want people not to like us because, that might hurt our sense of self-worth. I think we all know what it's like to be confronted with an ugly truth about what someone else really thinks about us. If it's a former friend calling you cringe, an ex thinking that you're lame or unattractive, you know, some asshole on the internet or from school, whatever. When someone makes a snide comment about your looks about any feature of you, that really hurts.
我们不希望别人不喜欢我们，因为那可能会伤害我们的自我价值感。我想我们都知道，当直面关于别人对我们的真实看法的残酷真相时，那是什么滋味。如果是一个前朋友说你很尴尬，一个前任觉得你很逊或没有吸引力，你知道的，互联网上的某个混蛋或学校里的某个人，不管是谁。当有人对你的外表或你的任何特征说出刻薄的评论时，这真的很伤人。
and we want to avoid that hurt, and we want to avoid the damage that it does to our self-esteem. So we begin to fear those judgments as a way to avoid them. But let's dissect that even further. If someone doesn't like you, then what? Well, for our anxious mind, if people don't like us, they think we're unattractive, annoying, whatever your primary insecurity is around being perceived, we worry that as a secondary consequence of that, we will lose really valuable relationships or opportunities for connection.
我们想要避免这种伤害，我们想要避免它对我们自尊造成的损害。所以我们开始害怕这些评判，以此来避开它们。但让我们进一步剖析这一点。如果有人不喜欢你，那又怎样？好吧，对于我们焦虑的大脑来说，如果人们不喜欢我们，他们认为我们没有吸引力、烦人，无论你对被审视的主要不安全感是什么，我们都会担心，作为其中的次要后果，我们将失去非常宝贵的人际关系或建立联系的机会。
That's a really primal instinct you have going on there. You don't want to be left out of the group. You want to avoid isolation and loneliness at all costs because our ancient brain knows that could harm us in the long run. Basically, this is our fear of rejection, kind of working in tandem with our desire for social acceptance and belonging. but actually that ends up driving a wedge between us and other people anyways because we end up, you know, letting this fear drive us to self-isolate,
你身上正上演着一种非常原始的本能。你不想被排除在群体之外。你不惜一切代价避免孤立和孤独，因为我们远古的大脑知道这从长远来看会伤害我们。基本上，这就是我们对拒绝的恐惧，与我们对社会接纳和归属感的渴望双管齐下。但实际上，这最终还是在我们和他人之间打下了楔子，因为我们最终，你知道的，让这种恐惧驱使我们自我隔离，
drive us to not put ourselves out there, to not really connect with people, which means that although our fear of being perceived might in our brains be protecting us from being embarrassed, from being excluded, from being teased or mocked, and therefore protect our social relationships, actually it's having the counter effect. And it's meaning that we tend to close ourselves off from those opportunities anyways. It's like if you begin to expect that people won't like you or will immediately think the worst of you, why give them the power to even do that when you can stop that from happening in the first place by never showing up? You can't be perceived if you're not present.
驱使我们不把自己展露出去，不去真正地与人建立联系，这意味着，尽管我们大脑中害怕被审视可能是在保护我们免受尴尬、排挤、戏弄或嘲笑，从而保护我们的人际关系，但实际上它产生了相反的效果。这意味着我们往往无论如何都会把这些机会拒之门外。这就像如果你开始预期人们不会喜欢你或者会立刻把你想得最坏，既然你可以从一开始就通过从未露面来阻止这种情况发生，为什么还要给他们这样做的权力呢？如果你不在场，你就不会被感知。
And so we tend to reduce our anxiety and our fear by reducing exposure to the trigger, which is other people or situations where we think we might be uncomfortable. I think we know all too well that this avoidance typically backfires, as avoidance always does when it comes to phobic behavior or anxiety. The less exposure you have, the more power your fear has because it begins to make everything seem worse in your brain and you have no lived experience. experience to prove otherwise. Like in this example, right, you believe that if people could perceive you, they would say something mean or cruel or would think that you were embarrassing and that would result in them not liking you, bad-mouthing you, having a negative judgment. The outcome of that is super scary. You can't handle that possibility and so you never let it be the case. But in your efforts to reduce your anxiety, which is a totally natural thing to do because anxiety obviously
因此，我们倾向于通过减少对触发因素（即其他人或我们认为可能会感到不舒服的情况）的接触来减少焦虑和恐惧。我想我们都太清楚了，这种回避通常会适得其反，就像面对恐惧症行为或焦虑时回避总是会产生反效果一样。你的接触越少，你的恐惧拥有的力量就越大，因为它开始让一切在你的大脑中看起来更糟糕，而你没有任何生活经验来证明并非如此。就像在这个例子中一样，对吧，你相信如果人们能感知到你，他们就会说刻薄或残酷的话，或者会认为你很尴尬，这会导致他们不喜欢你、说你坏话、对你产生负面评价。那个结果超级可怕。你无法承受那种可能性，所以你从不让它发生。但在你试图减少焦虑的努力中，这完全是一件很自然的事情，因为焦虑显然
makes us uncomfortable, we actually never question or give ourselves the opportunity to disprove this irrational hypothetical. Worse than that, we never give ourselves the opportunity to prove to ourselves that we are capable of feeling judged and pushing forwards anyway. We never get to prove to ourselves that we are bigger than what someone may or may not think. We can experience our worst fear and we can survive it and we can not just survive but it can fuel us and it can make us bigger and better and in some ways it actually reduces the initial fear that we had. So what are the consequences of this? Well I've kind of seen it in myself to be honest. In the past I remember self-abandoning a lot denying my true self kind of the opportunity to be vibrant and present because
让我们感到不舒服，我们实际上从未质疑过或给自己机会去反驳这种非理性的假设。更糟糕的是，我们从未给自己机会向自己证明，我们有能力感受到评判并无论如何都继续前行。我们永远无法向自己证明，我们比某人可能或不可能的想法更伟大。我们可以经历我们最害怕的恐惧，我们可以挺过来，我们不仅能活下来，它还能激励我们，让我们变得更宏大、更好，在某些方面，它实际上减少了我们最初的恐惧。那么这会带来什么后果呢？说实话，我自己在某种程度上也看到了这一点。在过去，我记得自己曾多次自我抛弃，否定了真实的自我，剥夺了展现活力和存在感的机会，因为
the fear was louder than my impulse to express myself and made me very very small and very very sad. At first I remember this very clearly like I'd be really excited to I don't know post a picture online or to express my opinion or to go to this party and talk to people or even just like create something cool and interesting and share it. And then this fear would infiltrate and make all those positive feelings and all that anticipation, it would wilt it. It would make it really, really small. And you push down the parts of you that you think are too much or that stick out a little bit too much. You avoid situations that you probably would have enjoyed and you deny yourself opportunities because a lot of opportunities do come with perception. The more successful you become.
恐惧的声音比我表达自己的冲动更响亮，这让我变得非常非常渺小，非常非常伤心。起初，我记得很清楚，比如我会非常兴奋地，我不知道，在网上发张照片，或者表达我的意见，或者去参加这个派对和大家聊天，甚至只是创造一些很酷很有趣的东西并分享它。然后这种恐惧就会渗透进来，把所有这些积极的感受和所有的期待都击得粉碎。它会让它变得非常非常小。你会压抑自己身上那些你认为太过分或有点太突兀的部分。你会避开那些你本会喜欢的场景，你会剥夺自己的机会，因为很多机会确实伴随着被感知。你越成功，
the more passionate you become, more people begin to notice you. And of course, if you can't handle that perception, why ever put yourself in a position where you could be praised or you could be seen? I think simply put, the desire to fit in and the paralyzing fear of being disliked, it undermines our ability to pursue the lives we want to create. The hypothetical views of people we don't even care about, let alone know, take on more power than our own intentions and our own dreams. It's really interesting because as one person put it to me, it's kind of like you put a wall between you
你变得越有热情，越多的人开始注意到你。当然，如果你无法承受那种感知，为什么还要把自己置于一个可能会受到赞扬或被人看见的位置呢？我觉得简而言之，融入集体的渴望和对被厌恶的麻痹性恐惧，破坏了我们追求想要的生活的能力。那些我们甚至不在乎、更不认识的人的假设观点，比我们自己的意图和梦想拥有更大的力量。这真的很有趣，正如一个人对我说的那样，这就像你在自己
and the world and you both resent that wall, but you also rely on it at the same time. At an extreme, our fear of being perceived can cause us to panic and experience heightened levels of social anxiety, terror, dread, shortness of breath, shaking the urge to go and hide. You know, and it's often in response to specific situations, like being introduced to new people, being in large group settings where you feel like the Yob won out, being the center of attention. So a question I've definitely asked myself, and I'm sure you may have as well, why does some people have this fear and others don't? there are people who are just not afraid in the slightest to exist as their fullest and truest selves
和世界之间筑起了一堵墙，你既痛恨这堵墙，但与此同时又依赖着它。极端情况下，我们对被审视的恐惧会引发恐慌，并经历高度的社交焦虑、恐怖、恐惧、气短、颤抖、想要去寻找藏身之处的冲动。你知道的，这通常是对特定情境的回应，比如被介绍给新朋友，处于你觉得自己格格不入的大型群体环境中，成为注意力的焦点。所以我肯定问过自己一个问题，我相信你可能也问过：为什么有些人有这种恐惧而其他人却没有？有些人哪怕一点也不害怕以最完整、最真实的自我存在
and we really admire them for that i'm sure we always have we all have someone in mind right now maybe it's like a pop culture figure like i don't know chapel rhone or like a performer or an idol of ours or even a friend who just seriously has no, just doesn't have that wall, doesn't have that wall between them and the world. So why exactly is it the case that we do? Where does this fear, where does this worry of being perceived truly come from? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我们真的非常钦佩他们，我相信我们一直都是这样。我们现在脑海中都有这样一个人，也许就像流行文化中的某个名人，比如，我不知道，沙佩尔·罗恩，或者某个表演者、我们的偶像，或者甚至是一个朋友，他们真的根本没有，根本没有那堵墙，在他们和世界之间没有那堵墙。那么，为什么我们偏偏会有呢？这种恐惧，这种对被审视的担忧究竟从何而来？2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只有2%。
I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
请收听《2%》。即数字2%。可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMAs 上双击小金的胸部吗？还是坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以去寻找答案。在 Look Back at it 播客中。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英国。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，
Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about
瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于
wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我和 Kear Games 的行列，在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索 learn the hard way 并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法院听证会暴露了她供词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。艾伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我动了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我整个人都惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Firstly, our fear of being perceived is really closely linked to a voice. course, social anxiety and anxiety in general, as most social and specific phobias are. What I really want people to know is that social anxiety is more than just shyness, it's more than just introversion, it's actually a complex difference in how our brains are reacting to our environment, including social interactions and specifically how they're wired to absorb this
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，事情还没结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。首先，我们对被审视的恐惧与一种声音。当然，还有社交焦虑以及普遍的焦虑，就像大多数社交恐惧症和特定恐惧症一样。我真正想让人们知道的是，社交焦虑不仅仅是害羞，它不仅仅是内向，它实际上是我们的神经系统对环境做出反应方式的一种复杂差异，包括社交互动，特别是它们如何被硬编码来吸收这些
information and the meaning that they apply to it. Mainly, social anxiety and with its scope of is attributed to a dysfunction in the hippocampus, the amygdala, and the areas of our brain that process emotion, meaning that there is a lot more activity in those specific regions, making us feel more attuned to small moments, small cues, that are kind of seen through like a fearful lens, that's the easiest way to put it. There are a lot of neural mechanisms that are simply different between people with social anxiety and people with scropophobia and people without it. And those neural mechanisms are caused by both genetics and our environment. But I think it's important that we acknowledge the neural and biological mechanisms controlling this fear at the very top of this.
信息以及它们赋予这些信息的意义。主要是，社交焦虑及其视野被归因于海马体、杏仁核以及大脑中处理情感的区域的功能障碍，这意味着这些特定区域有更多的活动，使我们对微小的时刻、微小的线索更加敏感，这些时刻和线索似乎是通过一种充满恐惧的镜头被看待的，这是最简单的表达方式。社交焦虑症患者、广场恐惧症患者与没有这些症状的人之间，存在着许多截然不同的神经机制。而这些神经机制是由基因和环境共同导致的。但我认为重要的是，我们在最开始就要承认控制这种恐惧的神经和生物学机制。
Because especially when maybe we encounter someone who just doesn't quite understand where our feel comes from, They really need to know, and I hope that they do know, that a lot of it is not really within our choice. It's not something that we have opted into. Actually, it's the way that we are built. It's why we also kind of see people who care so little about others' opinions and they possess zero self-awareness because they don't have that same neural makeup and those same kind of cross-activations between different regions of their brains that mean when they see a social
因为特别是当我们可能遇到一个根本不理解我们的恐惧从何而来的人时。他们真的需要知道，我也希望他们知道，这很大程度上并不是我们的选择。这不是我们自愿选择的。实际上，这是我们生来就有的结构。这也是为什么我们还会看到有些人对别人的意见毫不在乎，并且完全缺乏自我觉察，因为他们没有相同的神经构造，也没有大脑不同区域之间那种交叉激活，这意味着当他们看到一个社交
situation, when they see the potential for being judged, their fear centres kind of light up, they're hyper-aware, there is none of that going on. And it's kind of like the opposite side of the coin here. Like it's equally as confronting to see someone who genuinely doesn't care to a fault. but scropophobia can also arise from something really upsetting or traumatic that has happened at some point in your life, especially during childhood, especially around bullying, exclusion, isolation, public humiliation. Those events and situations can be actually quite shocking and very intense and so they leave a lifelong imprint and they cause behavioral and emotional changes. actually in some 40 to 60% of cases of scropophobia, people are able to trace their fear back to a catalyst event or a specific time in their lives when they were really going through it when they were really socially ostracized or isolated.
情境，当他们看到被评判的潜在可能时，他们的恐惧中枢并不会点亮，他们不会过度敏感，那些情况统统不存在。这有点像一枚硬币的另一面。就像看到一个真正盲目地不在乎的人同样让人感到不知所措。但广场恐惧症也可能源于在你生命中的某个时刻发生的一些非常令人沮丧或创伤性的事情，尤其是在童年时期，尤其是在涉及霸凌、排挤、孤立、公开羞辱时。这些事件和情况实际上可能相当具有冲击力并且非常强烈，因此它们留下了终生的印记，并引起行为和情感上的改变。实际上，在大约 40% 到 60% 的广场恐惧症病例中，人们能够将他们的恐惧追溯到一个催化事件或他们生命中的特定时期，当时他们确实经历了艰难时期，真正被社会排挤或孤立。
These situations can make us increasingly hyper-aware, firstly of how others see us, because we're trying to anticipate a situation where our biggest fears could be realized again. We already know what this feels like we didn't like it. And so we try and avoid anything that reminds us of a previous time when we were judged, when we were bullied, when we were excluded. And I do want to highlight bullying as an example here because it's definitely one that resonates with me a lot as like a kid who was bullied. I know I always say that I think children like that,
这些情况会让我们越来越高度敏感，首先是关于别人如何看待我们，因为我们试图预判这样一种情境：我们最大的恐惧可能会再次变成现实。我们已经知道这种感觉是什么样的了，而且我们不喜欢它。所以我们尽量避免任何让人想起过去那些我们被评判、被霸凌、被排挤的时刻的事情。我确实想在这里强调霸凌作为一个例子，因为作为一个曾经被霸凌过的孩子，这绝对是一个能引起我强烈共鸣的例子。我知道我总是说，我认为那样的儿童，
end up becoming quite interesting people because they learn to not, I guess, not rely on the external validation of others, but it can also make us go the complete opposite way, where that external validation of others becomes all we can think about. If you went through childhood, knowing what it felt like to be teased constantly, to have those whispers kind of follow you around online in person, and then you tried your hardest to avoid that experience. by wearing the clothes that made you fit in, by staying out of the way, by appeasing your bullies, and still finding that you couldn't escape it, that pain is not something that you easily forget. And so even as you age, it doesn't go away.
最终会成为非常有趣的人，因为他们学会了，我猜，不再依赖外部对他们的认可，但这也可能让我们走向完全相反的极端，以至于外部对我们的认可成了我们唯一能想到的事情。如果你在童年中度过，深知不断被戏弄是什么滋味，让那些闲言碎语无论在网上还是现实中都对你穷追不舍，然后你竭尽全力去避免那种经历。通过穿着能让你融入其中的衣服，通过保持低调，通过讨好你的霸凌者，却发现你依然无法逃脱，那种痛苦是不会轻易忘记的。所以即使随着年龄增长，它也没有消失。
Memories like that are interesting because from an evolutionary perspective, they're meant to help us, but they also contribute to trauma and PTSD. And in a paper published in 2011, researchers showed that harmful, painful memories typically actually have greater recall than positive memories from around the same time. So it's not like you can just forget and move on. That's like saying, oh, can you please forget what your best friend's name is? Can you forget what your first day of school was like? Can you forget your graduation?
这样的记忆很有趣，因为从进化的角度来看，它们是为了帮助我们，但它们也导致了创伤和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。在2011年发表的一篇论文中，研究人员表明，有害的、痛苦的记忆通常比同一时期左右的积极记忆具有更高的回溯率。所以你不能只是忘掉然后继续前行。这就好比说，哦，你能忘掉你最好朋友的名字吗？你能忘掉你上学第一天是什么样的吗？你能忘掉你的毕业典礼吗？
Can you forget the many times that you didn't feel like you belong? Can you forget the way that people's judgments made you feel? Of course we can't. It's ingrained in us. It's a permanent kind of fixture of our past and in some ways of our identity. The behaviours surrounding our fear of being perceived, scrutinized, judged, are actually, based on this understanding, they become defensive based on previous experiences. The possibility of going through that situation once more is so confronting that we learn what we need to do to avoid it from happening. and often how we avoid it from happening is to just avoid social situations. We've kind of already talked about how that can sustain this fear of being perceived even longer. But, you know, if it's all you're trying to do to survive, if it makes you feel better in the moment,
你能忘掉那些你觉得自己不属于那里的许多时刻吗？你能忘掉别人的评判带给你的感觉吗？我们当然做不到。它已经根深蒂固在我们体内。它是我们过去的一种永久性固定装置，在某种程度上也是我们身份的一部分。基于这种理解，围绕着我们对被审视、审视、评判的恐惧的行为，实际上变成了基于先前经验的防御。再次经历那种情况的可能性是如此令人难以承受，以至于我们学会了需要做些什么来阻止它再次发生。而我们通常如何阻止它发生呢？就是直接避开社交场合。我们之前已经讨论过这如何能使这种对被审视的恐惧持续更久。但是，你知道，如果这是你为了生存所能做的一切，如果它能让你在当下感觉更好，
sometimes it's hard not to do those things. It's hard not to, you know, both deeply crave social approval and also be, deeply terrified of it. I hope that explanation makes some sense. I also read a really fascinating article from disability rights activists that people with physical disabilities are also more likely to have a deep-rooted fear of being perceived because of again past experiences of being mocked, being pointed at, feeling those eyes on them in public, wherever they go,
有时很难不去做出这些选择。很难不去，你知道的，既深深渴望社会的认可，又同时对它感到深深的恐惧。我希望这个解释能说得通。我还读过残疾人权益活动家的一篇非常迷人的文章，文章指出有身体残疾的人也更有可能产生一种根深蒂固的害怕被审视的恐惧，原因同样是由于过去被嘲笑、被指指点点、无论走到哪里都感到那些目光落在自己身上的经历，
that constant recognition that you're being watched or that people have these private thoughts about you. that would be so much to manage. It would just be exhausting and very, very loud. The final thing that we have to briefly discuss here is actually perfectionism, which you may be surprised to hear come up in this kind of episode, but what we know about the fear of being perceived and what we know about perfectionism actually confirms that they are related in some very intuitive ways.
那种不断意识到自己正在被注视或人们对你有私下看法的认知，应对起来将是多么巨大的负担。那只会让人筋疲力尽，而且非常非常喧闹。我们在这里必须简要讨论的最后一件事其实是完美主义，听到它出现在这样一集节目中可能会让你感到惊讶，但我们对害怕被审视的了解以及我们对完美主义的了解实际上证实了它们在一些非常直观的方式上是相关的。
perfectionist set extremely high standards for themselves and they are often preoccupied with avoiding mistakes either social in nature, maybe academic, whatever it is that they are primarily fixated on. But this also causes them to become quite obsessed by flaws or imperfections that they believe will be noticed and criticized by others. the desire to appear perfect can create a very intense anxiety about being in the spotlight. Even if being in the spotlight is just being around other people, feeling like their eyes are on you, feeling like you have their attention, feeling like they are going to find that thing that you already know is wrong with you. actually this really interesting article published in psychology today which I feel like by now you guys know is my favorite place for sources on this. Actually it was published earlier this year and it notes that a fear of judgment or disapproval from others is actually the primary contributing factor to people managing perfectionism and it's also one of the primary contributing factors to people with scopophobia.
完美主义者为自己设定了极其高的标准，他们往往全神贯注于避免错误，无论是社交性质的、学业上的，还是他们主要关注的其他任何事情。但这也会导致他们对那些他们认为会被别人注意到并批评的缺陷或瑕疵变得十分痴迷。渴望表现完美的愿望会产生一种关于处于聚光灯下的强烈焦虑。即使处于聚光灯下仅仅意味着身处其他人周围，感觉他们的目光正注视着你，感觉你有他们的注意力，感觉他们会发现你已经知道自己身上存在的问题。实际上，这篇发表在《今日心理学》上的非常有趣的文章指出，我想你们现在觉得这是我获取这类资源的最爱去处了。实际上，它是在今年早些时候发表的，文章指出，害怕来自他人的评判或不赞同，实际上是人们应对完美主义的主要促成因素，它也是患有广场恐惧症的人的主要促成因素之一。
So in terms of like if you were to make an organizational chart or I guess like a way of categorizing different things that we can be going through mentally different fears, different conditions, different whatever. Scropophobia and perfectionism and a fear of judgment, all of those three things sit very, very closely together. They're probably only delineated by like a few percentiles. Let's take a step back though because we've kind of been circling around this question for the entire episode, but why does it even
所以，如果我们要画一张组织架构图，或者说用一种方式来分类我们精神上可能经历的不同事情、不同的恐惧、不同的状况以及各种感受——广场恐惧症、完美主义和对被评判的恐惧，这三者其实非常非常贴近。它们之间的差距可能只有区区百分之几。不过，我们还是退一步想想，因为我们在整集节目里都在绕着这个问题打转，但究竟为什么……
really matter? Why do people's opinions really matter? And I know we talked about social disapproval. I know we talked about belonging. I know we talked about perfectionism, about rejection. But truly, how life-changing is the opinion of someone we may never speak to again? How life-changing is that? What does that really have to do with us? How is that really going to hurt us? what is it about those judgments that feel so important to us? Because, you know, if you wouldn't invite someone into your house, why do we let them into our head? The burden of this fear is kind of thrust so heavily onto us,
这真的很重要？别人的看法真的那么重要吗？我知道我们谈过社会不容纳。我知道我们谈过归属感。我知道我们谈过完美主义、被拒绝。但说实话，一个我们可能再也不会和他说句话的人的看法，对人生的改变到底有多大？这种看法对人生的改变到底有多大？这跟我们到底有什么关系？这到底会怎样伤害我们？为什么那些评判对我们来说会显得如此重要？因为，你知道的，如果你都不会邀请某个人进你家，为什么我们要让他们进我们的脑海？这种恐惧的重担就这样沉重地压在我们身上，
whilst the people who, you know, are judging us, maybe not judging us, they kind of just get to go along their merry way. They never know what we're feeling, what we're changing, how we're hiding to be less seen, and it's costing you your life. and when I say your life, I mean it's costing you your freedom, your potential, it's costing you joy, relationships, opportunities, even if it's not something that you're consciously
而那些正在评判我们的人——也许也算不上评判我们——他们却可以高高兴兴地继续过他们自己的日子。他们永远不知道我们在感受什么、我们在做哪些改变、我们为了少被注意到而在如何隐藏自己，而这正在付出生命令的代价。当我说生命时，我的意思是它剥夺了你的自由、你的潜能，它剥夺了你的快乐、人际关系和各种机会，哪怕这不是你清醒时的
choosing. So what we really need to discuss is how we can break through that wall that is keeping us separated from a confident, self-assured, liberated life where the opinions of others kind of glide off us. They don't take up as much mental real estate. And I really want to help you with that. So I'm going to give you three powerful exercises and mental shifts that you can try today to overcome your fear of being perceived. After this short break, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
主动选择。所以我们真正需要探讨的是，如何才能突破那堵将我们与自信、笃定、解放的生活隔开的墙，在这种生活中，别人的看法会从我们身上滑落，它们不再占用那么多的精神空间。我真的很想在这方面帮帮你。因此，我要分享三个强有力的练习和思维转变，你今天就可以尝试，以此来克服你对被注视的恐惧。在这段简短的广告之后，欢迎回来。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇特的现代世界中，如何建立精神韧性、体能以及抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
收听《2%》。即在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO%。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人喜欢的时候？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期邀请马可·拉蒙特·hill的节目，畅谈80年代的快克。为了说清楚，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的意思是，马可，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也搬上台面了，所以……谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会如此全身心地投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们都在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。而且那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，让我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，
have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的官司，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，奥恩斯，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our fear of being perceived is built on a foundation of irrational thoughts, as most anxious patterns are. The irrational thoughts associated with our scopophobia sound like this.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·奥恩斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·奥恩斯已被控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们对被注视的恐惧建立在不理性的想法基础之上，就像大多数焦虑模式一样。与我们的广场恐惧症相关的不理性想法听起来是这样的：
Everyone is constantly judging me. People will remember every awkward thing that I do. If they don't like me, my life is over. If they don't think I'm funny, charming, good looking, they'll tell everyone and I'll lose all my friends. If these people at the party judge me, no one will speak to me anymore. These beliefs have probably helped you in the past
每个人都在无时无刻地评判我。人们会记住我做过的每一件尴尬的事。如果他们不喜欢我，我的人生就完蛋了。如果他们觉得我既不好笑、没有魅力、长得也不好看，他们会告诉所有人，我会失去所有的朋友。如果聚会上的这些人评判我，就不会有人再跟我说话了。这些信念过去可能曾帮助过你
stay away from situations that you thought were threatening or made you uncomfortable. but now they're just not useful anymore. And you know that because you're listening to this episode. The easiest way to deal with anxious thoughts like these is not to try and suppress them, ignore them, or even overthink your way out of them. It's to play the game,
远离那些你认为具有威胁性或让你感到不适的情境。但现在，它们已经不再有用了。你知道这一点，因为你正在收听这一集。应对这类焦虑想法的最简单方法，不是试图压制它们、忽视它们，甚至不是过度思考来摆脱它们。而是玩这个游戏，
the game of hypothetical that your anxiety is so great at. Every time you think that someone is judging you, tell yourself that they are actually admiring you, because why can't that be the case? What makes either of those scenarios more likely than the other? The fear-based scenario feels more likely because we're used to thinking that it's true. But is it? You might think, well, based on past experiences it is,
也就是你焦虑时最擅长的假设游戏。每当你觉得有人在评判你时，告诉自己其实他们是在欣赏你，因为为什么不能是这样呢？是什么让这两种情况中的任何一种比另一种更有可能发生？基于恐惧的那种情况感觉更有可能是真的，因为我们习惯了认为它是真的。但事实真的是这样吗？你可能会想，嗯，根据过去的经验确实如此，
but how many more times have people been able to perceive you and really loved your outfit or thought that you were really interesting or loved your smile and just not said anything? How many more times have people just not noticed you at all, never thought about you again, the same way that you have noticed people or not noticed people and never thought about them again? There is this idea in psychology that we pay more attention to the situations that already confirm bias for us. The bias in this situation is everyone is judging me.
但有多少次，其实人们能够注意到你，并且真的很喜欢你的穿搭，或者觉得你非常有趣，又或者很喜欢你的微笑，只是没有说出来而已？有多少次，人们根本就没有注意到你，从来没有再想起过你，就像你注意到或没有注意到某些人，却从来没有再想起过他们一样？心理学上有这样一个观点：我们更关注那些已经证实了我们偏见的局势。这种情况下的偏见就是：每个人都在评判我。
But it actually means that we don't see the full spectrum of all the other times. that that hasn't been the case. It doesn't matter, you know, whether that person is judging you or not. If you get into the habit of playing mind games with your mind games, it can be as simple as hearing that thought pop up, visualizing it, and having a laugh at yourself. Like, that's so funny. What a funny piece of false news my brain is trying to tell me. I have no evidence to suggest that in this moment, that person is judging me more than they
但这实际上意味着，我们没有看到其他所有并非如此的情况的全貌。你知道的，那个人到底有没有在评判你，其实并不重要。如果你养成了用思维游戏来对抗你的思维游戏的习惯，事情可以很简单，比如听到这个想法冒出来时，把它可视化，然后自嘲一下。比如：太搞笑了。我的大脑居然在试图编造这么荒谬的假新闻。我没有任何证据表明，此时此刻，那个人评判我的程度会超过他
are admiring me, more than they think that I am cool or funny or lovely. So that is our first mental shift, recognizing that you may think you know what's running through someone's head, but maybe you don't. And as always, quite frankly, it's none of your business. That's their problem. And what kind of a sad, frustrating life it would be if this person were to be judging you, not really knowing you, and if for their whole life all they do is just see the worse than someone. If that is what that person's reality is, how miserable would that?
们欣赏我的程度，超过他们认为我很酷、很有趣或很可爱的程度。所以，这就是我们的第一个思维转变：意识到你可能以为自己知道别人心里在想什么，但其实你并不知道。而且一如既往，坦白讲，这根本不管你的事。那是他们的问题。如果这个人一直在评判你，却根本不了解你，如果他们一辈子都在做的事情只是看到别人糟糕的一面，那将是多么悲哀、多么令人沮丧的人生。如果那是那个人的现实，那该有多凄凉？
that be? How just plain dark to see someone existing and to just have your mind immediately find something to scrutinize. What I'm trying to get at is that it says a lot more about them and they have a lot of bigger things to worry about than what you may or may not be doing because their their head is probably a really dark, insecure place and what a sad reality for them. I also find it useful if I'm still being met with the persistent thought that they're judging me, that they don't like me, to instead give that, to just kind of look at that hypothetical assessment and instead of being like I'm going to internalize their potential hatred of me, their potential disgust or embarrassment of me, I'm going to assume that that's what they're feeling and that's
仅仅看到一个人的存在，大脑就会立即挑出可以挑剔的东西，这该是多么阴暗啊。我想表达的是，这更多地反映了他们自己，他们有比你可能在做什么或没在做什么更重要的事情要操心，因为他们的脑海里可能是一个非常黑暗、缺乏安全感的地方，对他们来说，这真是一个悲哀的现实。我也发现，如果我仍然不断遇到他们正在评判我、他们不喜欢我的顽固想法时，换个做法会很有用——不要去审视那个假设性的评估，也不要去内化他们可能对我的憎恶、他们可能对我的厌恶或尴尬，而是假设那就是他们的感受，而这
fine and then I'm just going to flood them with unconditional love. In my mind, I'm going to look at this person, I'm going to perceive, think about this person, and I'm just going to imagine just shooting, like, just literally covering them in this big blanket of empathy and love from me. And it really does help you be like, I don't know, I guess in my mind I'm just like, it helps you see that this person might be thinking the worst on you and still going beyond not caring, being so defiant that you still like decide to give them love and you still decide to give them empathy what they're going through.
没关系，然后我只要用无条件的爱去包围他们。在我的心中，我会看着这个人，去注视、去思考这个人，我只会想象自己向他们倾注——就像字面意思那样，用我的一大片同理心和爱意将他们紧紧包裹。这真的能帮你做到这一点：我不知道，我想在我的心中，它能帮你看到这个人可能对你抱着最坏的想法，但你依然不去计较，依然如此叛逆地决定给予他们爱，决定对他们正在经历的事情给予同理心。
And that act of being the bigger person makes you realize that this person is not inherently better than you, not inherently, doesn't inherently know more than you. their opinion doesn't inherently mean more than yours because you're still here showing this great generous gift of loving them despite the fact that they could be really cruel to you in their mind. If that isn't working, I have another mental shift of you and it's called the yes and shift and no it's not the Ariana Grande song but honestly it's kind of a similar theme. The thing about anxious thoughts is that they feel quite real because they are like almost identical to a real fear but they're incomplete. They aren't fully
而这种表现得更大度的举动会让你意识到，这个人本质上并不比你更好，本质上并不比你知道得更多，他们的看法本质上并不比你的更有分量，因为你依然在这里展现出如此慷慨大方的礼物——尽管他们在心里可能对你非常残酷，你却依然选择去爱他们。如果这不管用，我还有另一个关于你的思维转变，它被称为“是的，而且”转变。不，它不是爱莉安娜·格兰德的歌，但说实话，主题确实有点相似。焦虑想法的一个特点是，它们感觉相当真实，因为它们几乎与真正的恐惧一模一样，但它们是不完整的。它们并不完全
formed and that's what causes them to feel so scary. This is the example I always give. It's like if you were to walk into a house and it looks like a house from the outside but the kitchen and the bedroom had no walls, you'd feel really exposed in a house like that and the same goes for an anxious thought. When you walk into an anxious thought and it's not entirely complete or real, you feel exposed to the possibilities that could fill those gaps, like being ostracized, being criticized. Here's how we overcome that. We overcome that by filling in those gaps ourselves before we let our anxiety do it for us, using our yes and method. So say you're at a party and you think someone is smirking at you or your behavior or cringing at you, talking
成型，而这正是它们让人感到如此可怕的原因。这就是我经常举的例子。这就好像你走进一栋房子，从外面看它像是一栋房子，但厨房和卧室却没有墙，你在这样的房子里会感到极度暴露。焦虑想法也是如此。当你走进一个并不完全完整或真实的焦虑想法时，你会暴露在那些可能填补这些空白的各种可能性中，比如被排挤、被批评。我们是这样克服这一点的。我们通过自己来填补这些空白，而不是让焦虑代劳，也就是使用我们的“是的，而且”方法。假设你在一个派对上，你觉得有人在对你或你的行为假笑、畏缩，或者正在和朋友
to their friends about you. In your brain, everything is probably alive and alive and rushing and scary and freaky. And you're probably thinking they don't like me. Now, what I want you to do here is accept that, yeah, maybe they don't like you. And then I want you to add an and onto that sentence. They don't like me and I'll be okay anyways. They don't like me and I know my friends love me, so I'm not too fussed by that. They don't like me and I'll never, see them again, so it really, that's fine by me. Don't let your fear grab onto that emptiness, that unknown space, that uncertainty, and spiral. Because if you let your fear take over the end, it will sound something like, they don't like me, and that means that everyone at this party doesn't
议论你。在你的大脑中，一切可能都充满生机、飞速运转、极其可怕而诡异。你可能在想：他们不喜欢我。现在，我要你在这里做的是：接受这一点——是的，也许他们确实不喜欢你。然后我希望你在那句话后面加上一个“而且”。他们不喜欢我，而且无论如何我都会好起来的。他们不喜欢我，而且我知道我的朋友们爱我，所以我对此并不是特别在意。他们不喜欢我，而且我再也不会见到他们了，所以这真的——我完全可以接受。别让你的恐惧抓住那种空虚感、未知空间和不确定性，并任由其螺旋式恶化。因为如果你让恐惧接管了后半句，听起来就会变成这样：他们不喜欢我，这就意味着派对上的每个人都
like me, and that means that maybe I should leave. So you kind of get where that ends up taking you. It takes you into a place of withdrawal, and I solicit. meaning you never face the fear. But what we really need to do is condition our mind to make peace with our fear of being perceived by replacing the worst case scenario that we so quickly jump to with a reaffirming statement or conclusion that really builds us up, that de-centers the opinion of this other person, and that makes us feel confident in whatever circumstance is about to occur. our final mental shift that we're going to discuss, I've come to call the mastery shift.
不喜欢我，这意味着也许我应该离开。所以你大概能明白这会把你带向何方。它会把你带向退缩和孤立。这意味着你永远不会直面恐惧。但我们真正需要做的是，通过用能够肯定我们、建立我们自信的陈述或结论，来取代我们总是飞速联想到的最坏情况，从而让我们的心态与对被注视的恐惧达成和解。这种结论会削弱另一个人看法的中心地位，让我们在即将发生的任何情况下都感到自信。我们要讨论的最后一个思维转变，我称之为“掌控转变”。
And it's based on principles of exposure therapy that are very often used to desensitized people with phobia from their fears. And it's used for things like a fear of snakes, a fear of planes, fear of bees. And we can use it for a fear of being perceived. So this is what I want you to do. I want you to make a list of 10 things that your fear. fear of being perceived is preventing you from doing. And I want you to order that list from the thing that you are most afraid to do that you cannot even imagine doing in a million years to the
它基于暴露疗法的原理，这种疗法经常用于帮助有特定恐惧症的人脱敏。它常用于对蛇的恐惧、对飞机的恐惧、对蜜蜂的恐惧。而我们可以用它来克服对被注视的恐惧。所以这就是我希望你做的。我希望你列出10件你的
thing you feel a little bit worried about, but you could try to borrow with enough support, with enough affirmations, with a really good dose of confidence. So I'll give you some examples of what could be on that list. Starting really small, it could be recording. Um, like a short video of yourself, talking about a topic and watching it back. It could be posting something you really want to post on social media on a private account, wearing an outfit that's bright or more out there than usual on public transport, wearing something that you know that you're shy to wear, offering to give a small speech at a friend's birthday, planning an event where you're going to be the centre of attention like a birthday party, going up to a group at a party
对被注视的恐惧阻碍你去做的事情。我希望你将这个列表排序：从你最害怕做、甚至做梦都不敢想象自己会去做的事情，一直排到那些你觉得有点担心，但如果有足够的支撑、有足够多的肯定、有充足的自信，你就可以试着去咬牙完成的事情。所以我可以给你举一些例子，看看什么可以列入这个清单。从小事做起，它可以是录制一段
who you don't know and introducing yourself, doing a huge presentation at work. What we want to do is start small. Start with those really small things. Like posting something on a private Instagram. Even if it's like for 24 hours, post a story, post a story to your close friends, just something really, really small. Wear that outfit, wear the thing that you would never wear. And once you can get through that situation without feeling true,
关于某个话题的短视频，比如录下自己并回看。它可以是在私人账号上发布一些你真的很想发到社交媒体上的内容，可以在公共交通工具上穿一套色彩鲜艳或比平时更张扬的服装，穿一件你知道自己会害羞的衣服，主动在朋友的生日上做个小演讲，策划一个你要成为全场焦点的活动比如生日派对，或者在派对上主动走到一群你不认识的人中间并进行自我介绍，又或者在工作做一场大型演讲。我们想要做的是从小事做起。从那些非常微小的事情开始。就像在私人 Instagram 上发个东西一样。哪怕只是维持24个小时，发个快拍，发给你的密友，只是一些非常非常小的事情。穿上那套衣服，穿上那些你平时绝不敢穿的衣服。一旦你能熬过那种情境，而没有感到真正的
ghastly or anxious, you move on to the next. We want to build up your tolerance, basically, to being seen, maybe being heard, being watched, perhaps even being judged. By showing you that A, rarely is the worst case scenario going to be the one that happens. B, even if it is, repeat after me, you will be okay, you will be okay. And finally, it starts to show you the possibility of a life without the fear of being perceived being the only thing that is motivating you. Finally, and one bonus shift that has helped me immensely in the past few years that I don't really have a name for, let's call it the ideal self-shift, is really focused on tuning into what do you actually want. I think one of the consequences of the fear of being
可怕或焦虑，你就可以进入下一个。基本上，我们要建立你对被注视、可能被倾听、被观察，甚至可能被评判的耐受力。通过向你证明：A，最坏的情况极少会发生。B，即使真的发生了，请跟我重复：你会好起来的，你会好起来的。最后，它开始向你展示这样一种生活可能性：不再让对被注视的恐惧成为你唯一的行动动力。最后，还有一个额外的转变，在过去几年里对我帮助极大，虽然我其实没有给它起名字，但我们就叫它“理想自我转变”吧。它真正专注的是去倾听：你内心真正想要的是什么？我认为，我们一直没有谈到的、对被注视的恐惧带来的后果之一，就是我们总是在考虑如何才能不冒犯别人，
perceived that we haven't spoken about is that we are always thinking about how to be less offensive to others, what they might expect from us, how to make us likable based on their tastes, their views, their ideas. It's, you know, hugely aligned with people placing, but it also disconnects us from what we need ourselves and who we want to be, because it's all about making others happy. De-prioritize the thoughts of others just for five minutes. What do you think about yourself? What do you think about yourself? And is that good enough for you? such that in five years time, you would be okay with still being this version of you. I really want you to sit with that for a second.
别人对我们有什么期望，如何根据他们的品味、观点和想法让自己变得讨人喜欢。你知道的，这在很大程度上与讨好他人有关，但它也让我们与我们自身真正的需求以及我们想成为什么样的人脱节了，因为这一切都是为了让别人开心。把别人的想法抛在脑后，哪怕就五分钟。你自己是怎么想的？你自己是怎么看待自己的？这对自己来说足够好了吗？以至于在五年后，你依然可以接受成为这样的自己。我真的希望你能花一秒钟好好想想这一点。
If no one else was around, who would you be? Would you like this version of you? How would you dress? How would you go about your daily life? What is your potential? And what's stopping you from being those things right now? Now I want you to think about what things you'd like to change and I want you to kind of decide
如果身边没有任何人，你会是谁？你会喜欢这个版本的自己吗？你会怎么穿衣打扮？你会如何度过你的日常生活？你的潜能是什么？是什么在阻止你现在就成为那些人？现在我想让你思考一下，有哪些事情是你想要改变的，并且我想让你自己决定
which of those things that you are hell-bent on changing or you think would make you happy are based on what you think other people expect from you and what you need to change for their approval and then I also want you to acknowledge what you want to change because you want to. What do you want to change for your life, the life that is yours?
在那些你下定决心要改变的、或者你认为能让你快乐的事情中，有哪些是基于你认为别人对你的期望，以及你为了迎合他们的认可而需要做出的改变；同时，我也希望你认识到，有哪些改变是你发自内心地想要去做的。为了你的人生，为了属于你自己的生活，你究竟想要改变什么？
and when you look at those two columns of things that you feel you need to change or who you need to be and you see the things that you feel you need to be for others and you see the things that you feel the need to be and you want to be for yourself anytime you find yourself focusing too much on that left-hand column I want you to shift back to the right concentrate all of your energy on that second column what I want for me the life I want for me the person I can become without this fear and keep it as a reminder for when you're worrying or obsessing over what someone does or doesn't think about you because you are the centre of all your experiences of your whole universe you are the one that matters here and I want
当你看着这两列清单时——一列是你觉得需要改变的、或者你认为自己必须成为的那种人，也就是你觉得为了别人而不得不成为的样子；另一列是你觉得需要改变的、并且你自己真心想成为的样子——每当你发现自己把过多的注意力放在左边那列时，我希望你把注意力切回右边，把所有的能量都集中在第二列上：我为自己想要什么，我为自己想要什么样的人生，没有这种恐惧我可以成为什么样的人。并把这作为一种提醒，每当你为别人的想法或不屑而担忧、痴迷时，都要想起它。因为你是你所有体验、你整个宇宙的中心，你才是这里最重要的人。我希望
you to be fiercely devoted to being your truest self even if it feels selfish or like you're disappointing others this is a muscle healing from our fear of being perceived is a muscle, it's a skill, and it's one of the greatest skills we can learn because it will transform your life. Please hear me when I say this. It's hard. It feels unnatural when you have been in this fearful state for so long.
你坚定不移地致力于成为最真实的自己，即使这感觉有点自私，或者像是在让别人失望。这是一个肌肉——从对被注视的恐惧中疗愈就像是一块肌肉，它是一种技能，也是我们能学到的最伟大的技能之一，因为它将彻底改变你的人生。请听我说：这很难。当你长期处于这种充满恐惧的状态时，这感觉很不自然。
But just the sense of freedom that you're one day going to have makes it so worth it. I really don't think that you need to be this fearful for the rest of your life. Even if you feel like right now, this fear is protecting you or that it's useful or it's helpful, I think you kind of know that it's no longer the case because you're here and you're listening to this episode and you want to change your life. And I think that that is something that once you are committed to, once you
但有朝一日你将拥有的那种自由感，会让这一切都无比值得。我真的不认为你需要在余生中都活得如此恐惧。即使你现在觉得这种恐惧是在保护你，或者觉得它有用、有帮助，我想你心里其实也清楚，事实已经不再是这样了，因为你来到了这里，正在听这一集节目，并且你想要改变自己的人生。而我认为，一旦你对此做出了承诺，一旦你
deprioritize the opinions of others, once you find the mental shift the mental game that works for you, it all becomes possible. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I do really hope that you enjoyed it. I hope that you learned something. I hope that you can take something away. I hope that you can get rid of your fear of being perceived. You can toss it out. That you can just look at other people as just other people doing their own thing the same way that you're doing your own thing. And really do the things, do the adventures, do the experiences that scare you and that have always scared you because of what others might think. And hopefully now you don't care. So if there is someone that you know who you think might need to,
不再把别人的看法放在首位，一旦你找到了适合自己的思维转变和心理游戏，这一切就都变得有可能了。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真的希望你们喜欢这一期。希望你们有所收获，希望你们能带走一些感悟，希望你们能摆脱对被注视的恐惧。你可以把它彻底扔掉。你可以把其他人仅仅看作是在过自己生活的人，就像你也在过自己的生活一样。去做那些事情吧，去经历那些冒险，去体验那些因为害怕别人的看法而一直让你感到恐惧的事情——而现在，希望你已经不在乎了。所以，如果你认识某个人，你觉得他可能需要
to hear this episode. Please feel free to share it with them, share it online, share it on Instagram. You can also DM me if you have additional thoughts, feelings, I don't know, hypotheticals. You can DM me at That Psychology Podcast. We're also taking episode suggestions at the moment and make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple and give us a five-star review if you enjoyed this episode. Until next time, stay gentle, be kind to yourself and we will be talking very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
听到这一集节目，请随时分享给他们，分享到网络上，分享到 Instagram 上。如果你有额外的想法、感受，或者我不知道，各种假设，你也可以私信我。你可以通过 @That Psychology Podcast 私信我。我们目前也在接受节目选题的建议，如果你喜欢这一期节目，请确保在 Spotify 或 Apple 上关注我们，并给我们留下五星好评。直到下一次，保持温柔，对自己好一点，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
在当今这个奇特的现代世界中，如何建立精神韧性、体能以及抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO%。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我的意义重大。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家们一起。比如马可·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games.
这是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不够安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人随身带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得去用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，奥恩斯，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男性。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·奥恩斯终于面临了后果。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档来自 IHeart 的播客。保证由真人创作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。